let's talk about porn because I'm sure
that's not going anywhere around the
Internet
Arizona's Republican Governor Jan Brewer
you know Jan Brewer she signed a law
this week cracking down on revenge porn
classifying it as a sex offense of
course revenge porn is when you post
photos or videos usually of an ex of
yours without their consent there's a
bunch of states that have this let's get
a little info on the law
Arizona's strict new law makes revenge
porn a felony establishing an initial 18
months in prison or two-and-a-half years
in prison if the person in the image can
easily be identified it will apply to
any photograph videotape film or digital
recording of a person and it makes it a
crime to disclose display distribute
publish advertise or offer these photos
or videos this seems all good to me I
usually don't agree with Jan Brewer but
this seems pretty good is there anything
wrong with this kind of law and did we
really just need this because that was
my question like why do we have to say
that you're not allowed to post
revealing photos of your ex on the
internet like that should be obvious
should be I mean it's ridiculous that
this even had to be said like don't be
an [ __ ] don't write people don't
murder people don't post pictures of
people on the internet for everyone to
see and invade their privacy like that's
common sense wasn't the original 11th
commandment thou shalt not post pictures
yeah all good here good Oh completely I
mean obviously this needs to be
legislated because people will argue
that this is a violation of free speech
and that they should have the right to
be able to say this and if there's
something in their possession especially
you know it gets complicated when
somebody takes a selfie and the
interesting thing is that some of these
revenge porn laws actually don't apply
to self recorded that in Arizona they do
but in other states some of them don't
apply to like self recorded images which
i think is a nuance that shouldn't be
written into the law but that's where I
think the legality gets confusing
because if I took a picture of myself
naked and gave it to you and said this
is now your property it's our
relationship
that's good don't judge us yeah yeah so
if I did that you should you know you
might be able to argue that it's now
your property and you can do whatever
you want with it
unfortunately there's no waiver signed
there's no relief there if there were a
waiver signed this revenge porn law
would not apply right if that's actually
not a terrible idea like have an app
where you're gonna send all your nudes
and you have to actually say reduction
all the time if I film you on the street
doing an interview and you don't want
your face on camera you can choose not
to sign the release and then you have to
blur your face out so the fact that
these are you know private experiences
that people will ultimately I think I
think that's kind of the interesting
thing about this law it's sort of like
the separation between a typical violent
crime and a hate crime because it's
motivated by something that's really
specific and really dark and kind of
violent and vengeful and because of that
direct motivation I think the penalty
should be stronger because the actual
act is is honestly like what is your
protection of that act like what can you
argue in a courtroom right that says oh
yeah I did that in good faith and it was
you know there's a price in that picture
to all my friends did a good thing yeah
I just wanted to promote it was great is
part of a problem here that we got all
this technology so fast you know what I
mean like the Internet is all it really
for for our purposes it's like 20 years
old you know I mean it's not that long
ago that it was all dial-up and we got
all of this stuff webcams and phone
cameras and snapchat we got it all so
fast that everybody started doing all of
this crazy stuff and now it's like we
need these laws to control us because
otherwise it's just endless right yeah
people are people are not the brightest
they'll just do whatever they can with
what they have I mean it's not the
technology's fault though I mean we have
a bunch of things at our disposal it's
your choice to be a jerk with it so no
at the technology's fault but definitely
people are going a little bit crazy and
you have to make laws like this we're
short-sighted as a society that's part
of the problem is that people make
decisions that seem good in the moment
and they don't think about the
ramifications down the line and it's
also difficult because there's no
legislation in place protecting
miners person and so yeah we argue in
this country all the time about the
legal drinking age the legal driving age
like at what point are you responsible
enough to operate heavy machinery or you
know take a substance that's
psychotropic and so yeah at what point
are you responsible enough to have a
camera and the ability to upload any
picture that you take onto the Internet
it's difficult when you're a young
person it's even harder to think about
the downstream ramifications and their
biological reasons for that that part of
your brain isn't well developed so and
we're also not socialized to have that
kind of responsibility at that age so
that's where things get difficult and
that's why I think it is so important to
have legislation like this yeah I am
totally on board we were all in
agreement there
[Music]